[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietry Sirin hallo und guten Abend
und mit mir im Studio ist wieder Kristin
Otto mit den News vom Sport guten Abend
und das haben wir heute für Sie
vorbereitet
Mission mehr Einigkeit bei der
Kabinettsklausur auf Schloss Meseberg
beschließt die Ampelkoalition 10 Punkte
um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln
Söder macht Druck Bayerns
Ministerpräsident setzt seinen Vize
Aiwanger in der Affäre mein
antisemitisches Flugblatt unter Zugzwang
mit einem Fragenkatalog
und dritter Sieg im dritten Spiel
Deutschlands Basketballer gewinnen bei
der WM in Asien auch gegen Finnland und
ziehen mit makelloser Bilanz in die
Zwischenrunde
nach fordernden Monaten voller
politischer Turbulenzen und
atmosphärischer Störungen trifft sich
die Bundesregierung seit heute auf
Schloss Meseberg und da gibt es einiges
zu besprechen zum einen wie etabliert
man ein neues wirgefühl und zum anderen
womit kurbelt man die schwächelnde
Wirtschaft an und zumindest in diesem
Punkt hat die Ampel konkrete
Vorstellungen entwickelt Danielson
berichtet
das gediegen geruhsame Ambiente trügt
ein wenig denn selten gab es so viele so
schrille Warnrufe aus der Wirtschaft wie
in den Tagen vor Meseberg die
Bundesregierung müsse jetzt entschieden
reagieren die Lage seit dramatisch
Botschaft angekommen so klang die drei
zuvor das adressierten Protagonisten bei
ihrer Antwort heute Nachmittag deshalb
ist es ganz ganz zentral dass wir in
dieser Situation an dieser Stelle eine
Offensive der Bundesregierung auf den
Weg bringen um Wachstum für unser Land
anzuregen dass wir noch mal einen Impuls
setzen Investitionen jetzt auszulösen
dass sogenannte Wachstumschancen gesetzt
ist so gedacht es geht nicht um einen
breitflächiges Konjunkturprogramm das
wäre nicht nötig es wäre sogar falsch
angesichts der jetzigen Inflation
Kernpunkte stattdessen eine
investitionsprämie für
klimaschutzinvestitionen erleichterte
abschreibungsregelungen für den
Wohnungsbau 6 Rand befristet auf sechs
Jahre und die steuerliche Unterstützung
kleinere und mittlere Unternehmen Umfang
und 7 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr nachdem
Lindners Gesetzentwurf letzte Woche noch
von der Familienministerin blockiert
worden war soll er morgen hier in
Meseberg verabschiedet werden zu wenig
und zu fokussiert auf die öko-wirtschaft
sei das kritisiert die Union gemäß
dieser Warnung vorab es ist eine erneute
Therapiesitzung der Bundesregierung wenn
Sie es ernst meinen und ernst nehmen
dann hören Sie auf zu streiten kommen zu
gemeinsamen Ergebnissen und geben vor
allen Dingen ein klares Signal zur
Stärkung unserer Volkswirtschaft ob dazu
auch der von vielen geforderte
industriestrompreis zählen wird ist
offen auch innerhalb der Ampel war der
bis zuletzt umstritten
Klaus brotbeck ist für uns vor Schloss
Meseberg Klaus es gab zuletzt der viele
interne Streitereien findet die Ampel
denn über die Sacharbeit wieder zu neuer
Einigkeit
man kann ja jedenfalls nur wünschen dass
das Klima drin im Schloss besser ist als
das Wetter hier draußen hier regnet es
den ganzen Tag je länger desto mehr die
Ampel hat aber gemerkt sie muss sich
besser präsentieren der Kanzler hat
heute Mittag gesagt wir haben eine
erstklassige Leistungsbilanz aber wir
müssen unsere Kommunikation umstellen
und das versucht mir jetzt hier also
nach dem mottour Gutes und rede auch gut
darüber geht man mit diesem 10
Punkteplan wie man selbst sagt in die
Offensive für das Land aber man darf
früher als auch sagen für die Ampel die
so ein bisschen aus ihrem Holper Betrieb
ja wieder herauskommen möchte man möchte
dann die Infrastruktur gehen man möchte
Investitionen angucken Bürokratie
abbauen vieles viel schneller machen die
entsprechenden Programme sind
verabschiedet worden wichtig ist aber
auch was noch nicht drin steht z.B der
industriestrompreis da sind die
Meinungen weit auseinander der
Finanzminister hat hier eben am Rande
der das der diese Veranstaltung hier
noch einmal bekräftigt das ist gar nicht
auf der
Tagesordnung stehe das ist kein
Notwendigkeit gäbe das zu entscheiden
und dass er weiterhin dagegen ist will
auch wie man weiß für den Kanzler und
insofern bin ich ziemlich sicher dass
egal wie das hier in Meseberg ausgeht
uns die Debatte um einem
industriestrompreis oder andere
Maßnahmen um die Industrie zu entlasten
in dieser Energie Hinsicht das ist diese
Debatte noch eine ganze Weile erhalten
bleiben wird vielen Dank für deine
Einschätzung Klaus nach Meseberg ja der
industriestrompreis ist in dieser
angespannten Wirtschaftslage jedenfalls
ein wichtiges aber eben auch
umstrittenes Thema wie gehört es die
Ampel da noch nicht auf einer Linie und
neuer lauter Streit soll sicher
vermieden werden aber auch Experten sind
uneins ob ein subventionierter
industriestrompreis die Situation
wirklich verbessert über das Pro und
Contra Christian Volk
Stahl für Kräne Züge und Busse made in
Germany das braucht Strom enorme Mengen
verteuert durch die Energiekrise seit
Monaten schlägt die Industrie Alarm
Firmen könnten ins Ausland wandern oder
pleite gehen es brauche sofort den vom
Wirtschaftsministerium geplanten
subventionierten industriestrompreis die
Industrie hat im Moment eine zweifache
Herausforderung auf der einen Seite
müssen wir die Situation managen mit
sehr hohen Kosten nach wie vor sehr hoch
und gleichzeitig die Transformation
Stimmen hey Richtung Nachhaltigkeit
aktuell gilt eine Preisbremse 13 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde für einen Großteil
des Stroms bis 2030 so die
subventionspläne sollen es für große
Unternehmen höchstens 6 Cent sein den
Rest kaufen Sie auf dem Markt dort gab
es bis vergangenes Jahr einen starken
Anstieg seitdem ist der Preis gesunken
und auf diesem Niveau wird er nach
Einschätzung von Ökonomen langfristig
auch bleiben befristete Subventionen
änderten nichts daran wir sehen das
Gaspreise hoch sind
dass die CO2-Preise steigern und die
Nachfrage nach Strom immer weiter
zunimmt wir brauchen mehr Strom für die
Speicher für die Elektromobilität für
die Wärmepumpen und um Wasserstoff zu
erzeugen und all das wird die Preise
auch perspektivisch oben halten außerdem
soll die Befürchtung könnte ein
industriestrompreis Innovationen
verhindern Kritiker bezeichnen ihn als
teuer und unfair gegenüber nicht
privilegierten Unternehmen und
Haushalten eine Alternative zum
industriestrompreis könnte die
Abschaffung der Stromsteuer sein
seit Anfang des Jahres hat die
Grundsicherung Hartz 4 einen neuen Namen
Bürgergeld heißen die Bezüge nun und die
werden jetzt deutlich angehoben in einer
Zeit in das sehr viele sehr dringend
brauchen wegen der Inflation werden die
Sätze deutlich um 12% angehoben mehr von
Karl Hinterleitner
den Start kostet es 4,3 Milliarden und
soll die Ärmsten besser stellen das
Bürgergeld erhöht sich vom kommenden
Jahr an um 12% statt 52 erhält eine
erwachsene ab dem ersten Januar 563 Euro
für Kinder und Jugendliche gibt es im
Alter entsprechend ebenfalls mehr der
Bundesarbeitsminister meint die
anhebungszeit dringend Gebote
das Ziel des Bürgergeldes ist es zum
einen Menschen verlässlich und
unbürokratische abzusichern aber vor
allen Dingen dafür zu sorgen dass
Menschen die Weg aus der Bedürftigkeit
finden nämlich in Arbeit und dafür haben
wir die Voraussetzung geschaffen die
linke Opposition und die Sozialverbände
begrüßen die Erhöhung grundsätzlich
meinen aber sie reiche nicht aus es ist
kein Verbesserung der Leistung sondern
es ist allenfalls ein bisschen ein
Ausgleich der Inflation aber die
bürgergeldsätze oder vor die
hartz-regelsätze waren vorher nicht
existenzsichert und das sind sie
natürlich jetzt auch nicht auch durch
diese Erhöhung nicht zwölf Prozent
Erhöhung wird nichts daran ändern dass
die Menschen die jetzt den Armut sind
dann auch in Armut bleiben nach unserem
Berechnung müsste der Regelsatz nicht um
12 sondern um 61% erhöht werden
utopisch meint die Union die jetzt die
gesteigerung sei in ihre Höhe angemessen
ich halte nichts davon jetzt hier eine
Debatte zu führen als sei man völlig
losgelöst von ökonomischen Grunddaten
die heute angekündigte Erhöhung gleicht
im Wesentlichen die Preissteigerungen
aus weitere Anpassungen gibt es ab jetzt
jedes Jahr
die Affäre um einen antisemitisches
Flugblatt durch Kreuz die wahlkampfpläne
der bayerischen Landesregierung
schließlich wird in sechs Wochen gewählt
deswegen hatten sich viele vom eilig
einberufenen Koalitionsausschuss heute
mehr erwartet Erklärungen des
vizeministerpräsidenten Aiwanger blieben
jedenfalls aus er soll nun erstmal einen
Fragenkatalog beantworten also vorerst
keine Konsequenzen für den Chef der
Freien Wähler Stefan leifert
ein langer Vormittag liegt hinter Markus
Söder und Hubert Aiwanger der CSU-Chef
kommt alleine es ist ein kurzes
Statement Nachfragen heute nicht erlaubt
Söder entscheidet in der causaiwanger
erstmal nichts zu entscheiden die
heutigen Aussagen reichen aber nicht aus
definitiv nicht aus für eine
abschließende Bewertung und Klärung es
blieben und bleiben viele Fragen offen
die Antworten darauf soll Aiwanger nun
schriftlich liefern 25 Fragen zu
Urheberschaft und Verbreitung des
Holocaust verhöhnenden Flugplatz bekommt
Aiwanger mit nach Hause ein Ultimatum
für die Aufklärung gibt es nicht ich
hätte erwartet dass Ministerpräsident
Söder jetzt rein Tisch macht stattdessen
scheint er auf Zeit zu spielen jetzt ist
es richtig dass der Bayerische Landtag
des Heftes Handelns in die Hand nimmt
hier muss Hubert Aiwanger jetzt dreht
und Antwort stehen und auch mit den
Vorwürfen wirklich aufräumen es geht
jetzt nicht um Wahlkampf es geht nicht
um Koalitionen sondern es geht darum
wirklich dass wir Schaden vom Freistaat
Bayern abwenden im Zusammenhang mit
diesem furchtbaren naziflugblatt es ist
kein Freispruch für Aiwanger so das Vize
bleibt vorerst Minister auf Bewährung
die Koalition will die CSU fortsetzen
notfalls auch ohne Aiwanger der Ball
liegt nun bei ihm Markus Söder kauft
sich und seiner Koalition damit Zeit
eine riskante Strategie denn die Krise
schwillt weiter Mark Söder auch den Ball
ins Feld von Hubert Aiwanger gespielt
haben diese Krise bleibt vorerst eine
gemeinsame so das Koalition geht mit
schwerer Hängepartie in die heiße
Wahlkampfphase fünfeinhalb Wochen vor
der Landtagswahl ist die Ausgangslage
offener denn je
eine junge Deutsche reist 2014 nach
Syrien um sich dort der
Terrororganisation is anzuschließen sie
heiratet und sieht später tatenlos zu
wie ihr Mann einen versklavt ist
jesidisches Kind in der prallen Sonne
festkettet das fünfjährige Mädchen
stirbt heute hat das Oberlandesgericht
München nach einer Revision das Strafmaß
für die is-rückkehrerin nach oben
korrigiert auf 14 Jahre Christoph
Schneider dazu
hinter Akten verdeckt betritt die
Angeklagte die deutsche is-rückkehrerin
Jennifer wie den Gerichtssaal und als
die Vorsitzende Richterin des neunten
strafsenarztes Oberlandesgerichts
München das Strafmaß verkündet nimmt sie
den Spruch regungslos zur Kenntnis die
Ankläger sind zufrieden
die Bundesanwaltschaft hat das
revisionsziel erreicht die Angeklagte
ist heute zu einer Gesamtfreiheitsstrafe
von 14 Jahren verurteilt worden das
Strafmaß liegt nur wenige Monate unter
dem Antrag der Bundesanwaltschaft für
das Gericht ist der Wiesen das Jennifer
weh gemeinsam mit ihrem bereits
verurteilten Ehemann als Anhänger des is
eine jesidische Frau und deren
fünfjährige Tochter im irakischen faluja
als Sklavinnen gehalten haben
tatenloser Jennifer wie zu wie ihr Mann
das Mädchen in der Hitze fesselte in der
prallen Sonne ließ und es starb dafür
erhielt wie es Mann eine lebenslange
Freiheitsstrafe sie selbst wurde
zunächst zu zehn Jahren Haft verurteilt
weil das Gericht ihre Tatbeteiligung als
minder schwer einstuftete aufgrund der
Menschen verachtenden
Handlungsmotivation von Jennifer weh
kommen die Richterinnen und Richter nun
zu einem schärferen Urteil
die Richterin und Richter haben heute
klargestellt Jennifer wie hat eine hohe
Strafe verdient für Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit sie hat zwei Menschen
versklavt und zugelassen dass ein
kleines Kind qualvoll sterben musste
gegen das Urteil kann doch Revision vor
dem Bundesgerichtshof in Karlsruhe
eingelegt werden
die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft hat die
Ermittlungen gegen Till Lindemann Sänger
der Bernd Ramstein eingestellt nach
Auswertung der verfügbaren Beweismittel
gebe es keine Hinweise dass Lindemann an
Frauen gegen deren Willen sexuelle
Handlungen vorgenommen habe die
Staatsanwaltschaft teilte mit das Opfer
oder Zeugen sich nicht gemeldet hätten
oder nicht auffindbar sein
der Chef der russischen Gruppe Wagner
Jewgeni prigorcin ist nach Angaben eines
Sprechers der Söldnertruppe auf einem
Friedhof in St Petersburg beigesetzt
worden im kleinen Kreis wie es hieß die
Zugänge wurden kontrolliert das Gelände
von der Polizei abgeriegelt der Kreml
hatte vorab bekannt gegeben Präsident
Putin werde nicht an der Beerdigung
teilnehmen
unser Korrespondent Armin Körper ist in
St Petersburg Armin um diese Beisetzung
hat es ein verwirrspüle gegeben warum
genau vier Friedhöfe wurden seit heute
früh für mögliche Beisetzungen in St
Petersburg abgeriegelt es wurden den
ganzen Tag über Falschmeldungen lanciert
welches mit welches Absturzopfer wann wo
beigesetzt werden könnte am Nachmittag
wurde dann tatsächlich einer der Wagner
Männer auf einem Friedhof beigesetzt das
wurde vorher an die Medien
durchgestochen so dass die dort alle hin
fuhren genau zeitgleich hat man hier auf
dem Friedhof wie ich jetzt stehe und der
hohen Sicherheitsaufwand wir gehen die
sind im Kreise seiner Familie beigesetzt
der Kreml hat damit sein Ziel erreicht
nämlich massenhafte Sympathiebekundungen
zu vermeiden und zu verhindern dass die
Bilder dieser Veranstaltung um die Welt
gehen denn mit dir gehen die prigosin
wurde heute der Leichname des Mannes der
im Westen fielen als Kriegsverbrecher
gilt und den Präsident Putin vor einem
Jahr gut noch als heltraulands
ausgezeichnet hat dessen Leichnam wurde
heute heimlich still und leise in der
Erde von St Petersburg begraben
danke schön für die Einschätzung nach St
Petersburg Armin Körper
ob Flugtickets Hotels oder Sonnenschirme
in Italien sind die Preise in der
Tourismusbranche massiv gestiegen so
kostet ein 7-tägiger Urlaub am Meer für
eine Familie mit zwei Kindern 19% mehr
als noch im vergangenen Jahr das rechnet
der nationale Verbraucherverband vor
insgesamt liegt die Teuerungsrate
aktuell bei mehr als sechs Prozent die
Folgen viele Italiener können sich den
Urlaub im eigenen Land nicht mehr
leisten Andreas Postel
Rimini legendäre Badeort an der Riviera
Adriatica an jedem Sommermorgen erwacht
dieses Meer aus Sonnenschirmen weißem
Sand und bellavita auch am Strand von
Irene metalli doch am Ende dieser Saison
hat sie deutlich weniger Strand liegen
vermietet
okay es hätte besser laufen können es
ist okay aber im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
gab es einen Rückgang
die Zahl der Menschen ist sehr stark
zurückgegangen sogar in der ferragoste
Woche von Mitte August waren nicht so
viele Leute da
wir haben unsere Art die Ferien zu
machen grundsätzlich geändert wir machen
jetzt eher nur vier oder fünf Tage
traditionell verbringen die Italiener
ihre Ferien im eigenen Land doch laut
nationalem Hotelverband haben in diesem
Jahr 40% darauf verzichtet
dieses zum Teil auf die Krise der
steigenden Hypothekenzinsen zum Teil auf
den energieschock der ersten sechs
Monate zurückzuführen einige haben also
ganz auf den Urlaub verzichtet andere
sind gefahren aber nur für wenige Tage
vor der corona-pandemie erwirtschaftete
der Tourismus 6% des italienischen
Bruttoinlandsprodukts die Regierung
erwartete nun eine super Saison
doch auch hier im römischen Stadtteil
gabatella aus dem Regierungschef in
Georgia Meloni stammt haben die Leute
Probleme wegen der hohen Preise für
Lebensmittel und Benzin es kotzt mich an
ich muss zusehen wie die anderen
wegfahren und ich muss hier in Rom
bleiben
glücklich wer den Strand vor der eigenen
Haustür hat auch wenn das nicht den
Sommerurlaub ersetzt der so die Hoffnung
zur nächsten Saison auch für die
Italiener wieder erschwinglicher wird
und jetzt ein besonderer Blick in die
deutsche Vergangenheit es gibt immer
weniger Zeitzeugen die aus der Zeit des
Nationalsozialismus erzählen können aber
wie bewahrt man deren Vermächtnis deren
Erinnerungen und Geschichte das haben
sich Historiker und die filmuni
Babelsberg zur Aufgabe gemacht mit
modernster Technik und dem Ziel vor
allem junge Menschen zu erreichen über
diese wegweisende Ausstellung Katrin
Lindner
zur Eröffnung der Ausstellung kommt Ruth
Winkelmann selbst die 94-jährige weiß NS
Zeitzeugen wie sie werden immer weniger
nun erscheint sie jederzeit wie in echt
auch in dieser Brille ein Abbild ihrer
selbst also mir ist es alles willkommen
wenn meine Geschichte dadurch
weitergetragen wird deshalb hat sie ihr
Leben in 36 Kameras erzählt danke ihre
Hilfe wird Ruth Winkelmann wie in echt
erzeugt und jeder kann ihn begegnen der
eine VR Brille aufsetzt unsere Kamera
kann das leider nicht einfangen sie hat
erzählt wie die Mutter gezwungen wurde
sich von ihrem jüdischen Vater scheiden
zu lassen er wurde ermordet wie alle
jüdischen Familienmitglieder sie ist
eine von fünf Zeitzeugen die jetzt
virtuell auf Reisen gehen in den Jahren
werden die meisten Zeitzeugen oder
verstorben sein und es wird keinen
direkten Begegnung mehr geben und was
wir ermöglichen experience ist dass man
den Holocaust Überlebenden physisch
begegnen kann mit einem
dreidimensionalen Abbild Schüler sind
die Hauptzielgruppe für dieses Projekt
deshalb hat eine neunte Potsdamer Klasse
an der Wanderausstellung mitgearbeitet
die auch an Orte gehen wird wo
rechtsextreme Gewalt aufgetreten ist es
wirkt für echter als würde man so aufs
um 2d-tablett sehen deswegen ich finde
das richtig cool das ist fast wie in
echt ist einfach man kann es noch mal
viel besser verstehen bisschen Leuten
halt wirklich ging in der Pilotphase
geht die Ausstellung in Brandenburg auf
Tour danach soll sie durch Deutschland
ziehen und gern noch viel weiter
so jetzt zur Basketball
Weltmeisterschaft und Christian da
bleibt die deutsche Mannschaft auch
Erfolgskurs bisher läuft so gut wie nie
zuvor zum ersten Mal sind deutsche
Basketballer mit drei Siegen
nacheinander in einen WM-Turnier
gestartet nach Gastgeber Japan und
Australien wurde auch gegen Finnland
klar gewonnen und die Gruppenphase ohne
Punktverlust abgeschlossen
souveräne Vorstellung von Deutschland
die sogar nba-legende und Edelfan Dirk
Nowitzki mitreist allerdings der Favorit
mit Anlaufschwierigkeiten Finnlands
Führung im ersten Viertel schnell
behoben Deutschland wieder ohne
NBA-Profi Franz Wagner hoch überlegen
angeführt von überzeugenden Lieder
Dennis Schröder die noch sieglosen
finden deklassiert nach der Pause das
Spiel früh entschieden Moritz Wagner
knackte mit dem letzten deutschen Wurf
dann die 100 Punkte Marke 101 zu 75 die
Gruppenphase problemlos gemeistert wir
können das heute feiern und dann morgen
ist das aber auch wieder vergessen weil
wir uns fokussieren müssen auch die
nächsten Spiele in der Zwischenrunde
könnte Deutschland unter anderem aus
Slowenien und Superstar Luca doncic
treffen
zum Tennis gut gespielt und dennoch
traurig Laura Siegemund nach ihrer
ersten Niederlage bei den US Open in New
York gegen die Amerikanerin Coca total
verärgert und fast untröstlich
die Tränen kommen nicht so sehr wegen
der Niederlage die Umstände sind es
einen Punkt Abzug bekommt Laura
Siegemund in der Schlussphase nach zwei
Zeitstrafen und den wiederholten
Beschwerden von Gegnerin Goff über ihr
langsames Spiel die Zuschauer sind
ohnehin schon gegen sie seit sie den
ersten Satz gewonnen hat ich fand es
teilweise respektlos wie mispublikum
behandelt hat keine Frage ich muss
einfach schneller sein ja aber ja so ein
Ding draus zu machen das habe ich jetzt
auch noch nicht so oft erlebt Siegemund
verliert den drei Sätzen das Publikum
wird sie wiedersehen im Doppel und dem
Mixed Wettbewerb
bei den Männern spielt gerade
alexandersverif sieht ganz gut aus aha
dann vielen Dank Christin der Deutsche
Wetterdienst warnt vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen im Süden Bayerns das geht
noch bis morgen früh und mehr dazu zum
Wetter gleich mit Christa Orden für
gewohnten Zeit um 21:45 Uhr dann das
heute journal mit Christian Sievers das
war's von uns schönen Abend und wenn Sie
mögen bis morgen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend zum Wetter der
Dauerregen der in den Alpen die extremen
Regenmengen brachte findet so langsam
sein Ende die entsprechenden
tiefdruckzentren hier verlagern sich
jetzt langsam in Richtung Osten aber
über der Nordsee steht schon ein neues
Tief in den Startlöchern und das bringt
uns morgen von Nordwesten Schauer und
kurze Gewitter heute Nacht kühlt es erst
einmal ab auf 14 Grad direkt an der See
und 8 Grad in der Eifel oder auch an den
Alpen und hier an den Alpen regnet es
heute Nacht noch am längsten bzw schneit
es auch noch oberhalb von 2000 m und
morgen Vormittag lässt dann der letzte
Regen an Oder und Neiße und im Südosten
langsam nach dann ist es weitgehend
trocken und weg sind bewölkt im Westen
Nordwesten da kündigt sich aber mit
ersten Schauern schon die Front dieses
neuen Tiefs an und die kann nachmittags
im Westen auch mal für kräftigeren Regen
sorgen zumal sich da auch vor laufend
über der Mitte schon Schauer und kurze
Gewitter bilden können bei einem mäßigen
südwestlichen Wind je weiter wir
Richtung Osten und Richtung Süden
schauen desto ruhiger wird der Tag am
Nachmittag die Temperaturen sind immer
noch gedämpft bei 16 Grad an den Alpen
und 22 Grad am Rhein zum Wochenende
steigen die Temperaturen und auch die
sonnenanteile zumindest im Süden wieder
etwas an in der Mitte und im Norden
bleibt es aber wechselhaft und damit auf
Wiedersehen